i don't know what this is something out
of my nightmares that's for sure
i know that i hate it i know that i hate
it a lot this is an abomination
horrible okay can i um oh my god you
you tried to kill me
it just tried to kill me
wait a second my lighting isn't right
but oh my god you just tried to kill me
hi
welcome back to pogo stock i am fine
this game starts off exactly as i
thought it would
where's my sound where's the where's the
game sound what
hello oh okay so from what i've gathered
about this section from seeing people go
by
is that i'm supposed to flippy flop from
here
land on that mag it and then use it as a
bounce to go
through the cocoa nuts and in doing so
going to the other side of which i have
no idea what is on the other side so i'm
gonna do exactly
that oh interesting that's
fascinating i don't wha please no not
like this oh my god i'm not
ready just please go up and down okay
here we go here we go
no it's fine because i can do
oh my god so that well that's a problem
well if if that but but that's a problem
okay here we go ouchies
okay no no no my god please not like
this
okay easy peasy easy peasy can i please
ease my pieces
ease the peas oh no not like this oh my
god oh my god
oh what am i so worried about oh
that's exactly what i was worried about
okay i'm up
[Music]
here we go i don't know where i'm going
i don't know where i'm going i don't
know where i'm going
oh no where am i going i don't know
ah oh my god no no okay it's fine
recovered it
what is that glow thing no oh
my god oh i'm here okay oh my god
okay okay
well there goes all my chances yeah what
is the shining glowing
no i didn't want to do it all the way up
oh what was that slip
i bounced but i slipped what
that's not a mechanic in this game oh no
that's not good okay yeah i mean
i oh that was too much that was too much
okay this is baloney and a half okay and
i don't know what happened also because
everyone's gone so i guess i'm
i get my peace and quiet now even though
i'm back at the beginning
so that's good that's good back at the
beginning i guess i wasn't that far
i was only a tenth of the way through
the game
that's okay progress is a lie anyway
uh what was even that
you know that's probably a better more
consistent strategy than doing anything
else because
just going down and then oh i hate that
oh the the slip is what i don't what is
the slip
i i do the slip all the time but i just
like that
what is the slip why does it slip it's
like a no
traction it's when i'm trying to make a
fine move like that
what what is that
oh my god really really
now and then i let go of course that's
why i
i hold down the boom button all the way
of time
because if i ever let go then i might
miss out on opportunity oh i forgot i
needed to let go
that's like a need oh what
ouchies why you ow
why you ow why how can you ow you know
there are so many more people that are
why was that not kaboom
why was that kabounce why would you
be anything that you are my goodness
you know how pathetic you sound how much
of a whiny [ __ ] you sound always
complaining about something
never taking any responsibility for your
own actions
oh maybe you ever think about it you're
not good enough you ever think about
that
huh no because you're always blaming
others because you're always looking for
someone else to blame if it's ever
yourself your own ego couldn't
crushingly take it so you got to take
out all your frustrations on
everything around you the game's broken
oh everyone's wrong
my pogo stick is too my i mean my took
his hurts cause i hit it on the wall
caveman who i'm talking about that's you
and you just can't admit to the truth
okay i did not think that was gonna make
it that was within a very tight window
of
error boing boing oh
why did i try to flip why would i try to
flip there why would that be
what i tried to do that's awful that's
so
awful i'm so sad
no no what what
what i don't oh my god please go a
little left
so you can go a lot of right oh my god
you've oh no
you suck dong so
ah that's my fault but the other ones
was all your fault see
i'm humble because i take responsibility
for my actions
unlike you mr caveman unlike you
oh don't pretend like that hurt
oh wow okay
great good wow dude you're so
funny you're so funny you s you do the
most
random things uh you're the little
random of games you know
and i love that in games i love that
everyone knows how much i love that
in games
oh oh
oh oh that was so disgusting i wanted to
throw up
okay oh oh
my god i'm gonna vomit cause you suck
that was not a super and why what's your
excuse
oh my god just do the super jump please
for the love of
goose
i was not i didn't think i was gonna
make it so i was like ah
i won't try hard
[Applause]
i love love
this game this game so good guys it's so
good it's so
good it's so good it's so good
would love to just try the thing that i
was just got to
would love would love to just try the
thing
you know the cool thing that i got to
the next step
the next stage the new stuff you know
that stuff i would
really like to try that that would be
really cool if i could try that
stuff the stuff you remember the stuff
everyone remembers this stuff
everyone at home if you remember the
stuff you let me know in the comments
and you let me know by slapping the
sweet stuff acknowledgement button
you'll know it when you see it looks
like a thumbs up
it means that you know the stuff of what
i'm talking about
and if you know the stuff you're part of
the new stuff knowing club
welcome thanks for being a supporter of
knowing stuff
and i'm really proud of the stuff that i
know and you should be
too because oh my god what was even that
why did that not get me up higher anyway
as a part of the new stuff
knowing club you will be subscribed to
all the stuff that i know which i put
out in regularly scheduled videos that
come out on a very consistent daily
basis
you will then know all the stuff that i
in okay
know and you will be able to tell your
friends and family that hey
i know the same stuff as that guy on
the internet knows and that's pretty
cool
oh really
that's interesting
super interesting wow
oh so interesting
fascinating actually fascinating oh
wow good oh good
stuff man man you know the stuff
god they're subscribed to the stuff
knowing
i can't believe that so many people and
this game
i'm done with the bit the bid is over
oh my goodness
oh that's just how good i am everybody
yes yes okay i'm here okay i'm back here
i did this before i should be able to do
it again boom baby i did it
yes yes yes oh my god no not like this
oh my god not like this
oh my god not like this oh yeah oh
that's the no that's not the stuff
but this is the stuff yes i've done the
stuff
i've i've done this the stuff is done
boom baby the stuff the stuff ah
i'm on fire now god damn it the stuff
oh my god all my stuff no okay i'm fine
now
oh
no oh my god
oh it's physically now
oh no no no the ceiling always gets me
oh god i hate the ceiling i hate it i
hate it so
oh my god
there's what is wrong oh my god what is
wrong with you
what is wrong with you why would you do
that to me why would you do that to me
why would you think that would be okay
to do
oh it's not super that's super okay
by the way that's fine it's fine that
it's not super
cause honestly why would it be that
would be weird if it was
you know what i mean it would just be
bizarre i wouldn't understand
why it would be oh that's oh my god it
worked i
bled
there we go that's how you do it a
little more consistently
okay here we go no no no no no no
not like that yes
yes way oh
no no i get there for
half a second and then it's gone why
would they add the milk of
failure why would they add the jizz
trail
why would they do that that's not how
you get through that part and i know
that
i'm getting tilted oh i'm getting heated
oh why you [ __ ]
no god and every time you hit the maggot
you lose all your momentum
ah yes oh i just had to say
something i just had to go yeah i nailed
it
i did it oh good thing oh my god really
oh no no don't um
oh my god really no do not oh
wow
no oh my god
oh my god
yes it's not necessarily that you need
to always do a complete 360 to get the
boost
it's just what
what did you just grab and you don't
have boost there
oh my god oh
my god oh my god
oh my god just go i'm trying to predict
what stupid behavior it's gonna have
and it always surprises me always every
time
it's some new inane [ __ ] that i have
to deal with
it's some new crap that's just never
i've never seen that before how many
times can i say
i've never seen that before oh
my god
thank goodness thank goodness okay
here we go baby this is the one
this is the one yes
no god damn it oh my god no not like
this
okay yes we're fine we've got this
recover
recover recover recovered
why is that not a boost it's okay
[Music]
yes that's how you do yes no
no oh yes yes
oh my god oh my god oh my god yes yes
yes
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay stop
oh i'm good
okay good great that's good
what is that i don't know i don't care
it's all good
all right hey cool
let's see what hell
is awaiting us and if i fall down i'm
ending the episode immediately
oh my god
oh my god no
nope oh my god no
i swear i'm it all these bugs and birds
are meant to distract
their their only purpose is to distract
you and it
works and i don't like that oh my god
oh my god nope nope nope nope nope stop
nope oh my god no
oh my god no
oh you sack
oh no no no
oh my god please no yeah my god
you sack of turd no
oh my god please stop doing oh my god
oh my god
thank you everybody so much for watching
i love you
hope you have a lovely day let's
subscribe for more
ring the bell ring it
[Music]
ring the damn bell you owe me that much
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you